JUHA UOTILA: All right.
So I'm Juha from Hookle.
You may remember--
SPEAKER 1: Excuse me, sir.
JUHA UOTILA: You may
remember my business partners
praising Flutter during
the keynote speech,
and I'm here to keep it up.
So I'll talk a bit about
Flutter from the perspective
of software development in a
high-growth startup company.
So we are a young company.
We just started five months ago.
And we're really trying
to go light speed.
And my idea is to develop a
mobile social media management
app that would be easy to
use, smooth user interface,
and so on.
So basically, our
strategic purpose
was to really focus on
the user experience.
So web app development
wasn't an option.
What we needed was the smooth
user experience and pretty much
native-like performance.
So basically, we couldn't think
of going web app development.
Although we did want the
app for both iOS and Android
in a cost-efficient
way, it kind of
seemed that we couldn't get
all of these that we wanted.
So originally, during the
summer for about a month,
our plan was to
go Android first.
So forget about iOS, since it
seemed impossible to do all
that we wanted to do.
However, one of our
developers, Jere, who's here,
suggested that we
can go Flutter.
Maybe that would help
solve our problems.
So we looked into it.
And for our purposes,
Flutter seemed
to have exactly what we needed--
basically, more or less
native-like performance,
cross-platform development,
and it seemed stable enough.
However, it was still
in this alpha phase,
and we were kind of worried,
as we were a small startup,
and it would be betting our
company on a new technology.
So we started doing
due diligence.
And it basically
took us two months
of looking into the
technology, looking
into what you can do with
it, how stable it is, and so
on, to finally
decided to go Flutter.
And when we did--
well, it's basically the
best decision we made.
It took us less
than half the time
of what we took to actually
look into the technology
to actually develop
a first working demo
that we could then
show to investors
and to use for customer testing.
So basically, in one month
from the start of coding,
we had a working demo
for both iOS and Android
that we presented in a big
Finnish startup event, Slush,
in Helsinki, and all of this was
basically done by Jere himself.
So I am obviously not
the technology guy.
I'm a business guy.
But I had some talk
with our developers,
or Jere in particular,
and the things
that came out about Flutter
and why it was so great.
The two things that
he wanted to bring up
was, first of all,
the customization
of user interface.
So apparently, the
customization of UI features
is something that's
quite unique for Flutter
and that you can do really
easy and really well.
But another thing
that we already
heard people talk here about
is the hot reload with states
option that radically speeds
up product development.
And in terms of technology, we
really haven't had any issues.
So I mean, even though
it's still in alpha stage,
it hasn't caused us literally
any problems on the technology
front.
So as already mentioned, we have
now the working beta version
that has the
back-end integration.
You can use it to manage
your social media.
At this point, you can do
Facebook and Twitter with it.
So download it for
either iOS or Google
or Android for Google Play or
from our website hookle.net.
So it has all kinds
of cool features.
It uses all kinds of
cool Flutter technology
that I don't know
anything about.
But when you download it
and look how great it is,
you can ask Jere how he did it.
Jere, can you stand up?
[APPLAUSE]
So Jere basically
did it himself.
So download our app
and try to break it,
because you're testing it.
You're beta testing it.
So try to break it, and
if you can break it,
tell Jere what you
did and he'll fix it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]